look at him used to kill people get
stale it's a cute kid man
oh shoot chin today's what's the first
thing I said to you when I walked in i
am the motorcycle man in the flesh now
hold on you know I love you Ben Luke
Rockhold
so why did you lie to him are we rolling
you want a roll yeah we die do it why do
i said i walked in i saw Matt I got he's
gotten thicker he's got some great
sleeve down at best
thanks Matt Matt's right or a writer of
new book called thank you for my service
yeah but you lied to hold on I die okay
hold on I had to call your brother was
with Luke Rockhold yesterday now hold on
top 10 best looking human being there's
no question that a woman there's no good
looking guy man I don't like how to give
it's not insecure when we watch MMA
fights and he walks out and I'm like
yeah yeah nah nah well yeah this real
package man I got it all you know take
it easy let me do the me how my ego just
jumped in on that like Oh Matt take it
easy let me [ __ ] go man that has
better skin dang well but that's not I
said to him I walk can I go you the
best-looking man I've ever seen in
person
he got him gave me a hug said thank you
now I also said for a guy's been through
war you've got great skin that's what I
said you you know now you're wearing a
lot you're wearing about an inch of
makeup hey give it up bro we know it's
the skin hits people I actually put
makeup on my peers before I came in here
cuz I didn't know where the show was
gonna go so so there's no shoes on your
car yeah
[Music]
it's about you dude rough night he's
little insecure honest looks you know
this is life dude he's nice he's gonna
say he's looking a little thick like I'm
- yeah I was to 70 up to 61 right now
I'm not true but he was to seven guys
you know we should get a scale on their
love cat shirt I'm all over the place
right now but I love cats [ __ ] shirt
now back to Matt and how he makes you
look like a piece of [ __ ] that's not
sure I have I'm good looking good you're
good and your personality you know
trumps looks all because I always look
at people being attractive in this way
this is not a 1 to 10 scale to 20 scale
marry me 1 to 10 on looks 1 to town
personality yeah so if you got
smoke show that's a ten but a two on the
person a let me up well if you love it
no they're not one night right now
you're right that like I'm talking
abilities eight ability I'm liking this
yeah you want a fifteen at least right
above fifteenth great eighteen is like
holy [ __ ] yeah eighteen twenty is
probably a training all right well
personnel twenties your best friend is a
[ __ ] yeah you know I know you do
sometimes wish that your friends had
tits cuz you just be or think if I had a
blog as a good I do and it's some tits
yeah and did you are dick you and I
would be set we'd be set did you ever
see the guy that lost that bet or I
think his friend paid him like a hundred
thousand dollars order was to get his to
two implants and then he left them on
like I didn't want to remove that's
insane I love them well Tonto
Tony Tommy Morrison the boxer got fake
got chest implants oh really but that's
different than it's like when dudes get
Cathy that's different
he's not mother nobody's hitting but
Tommy Morris I've got you think it's
well take a look at that
oh oh no he hold up he got implants
because he had horrible guy no and yet
[ __ ] was going on that's just a bit why
didn't you get masse removal he died of
AIDS I think oh he was doing some weird
[ __ ] yeah that's some work that's some
weird [ __ ] hey man that's not the point
is though is these time I do with real
tits though real tits yeah like Street
4:57 I am actually a breast
enthusiast myself so I know quite a bit
about the process implementation of them
however yeah I see any workouts either
no no when I have a shitty personality
you need to kind of look good so that's
right the [ __ ] face to make it easy
I wanna see him shoot you what I don't
know why I don't know where could you
shoot me where I wouldn't like cause
name major damage I don't point firearm
to anybody unless I'm there they need to
we should be talking we really shouldn't
but I definitely do promise it's not
getting on the podcast we're gonna have
a conversation after about some some
firearm stuff education a my sigh so you
get my son I thought we should have it
on here though yeah I'd like to get your
time love you your take
sure yeah but we'll get into that yeah
have you seen that jihadi john'
documentary on HBO
mmm-hmm oh my god don't see you in here
no
it's about the the other guy for Isis
would do all the propaganda and he's the
one cutting everyone's head out it's
about how he was a normal dude grew up
in London London yeah and how we went
jihad and what radio show path it was a
path but he didn't start it's he's not
though he didn't start off that way he
was like a normal dude played soccer and
normal family and then but guys like
that when they have an opportunity to
kill like I feel like so should I kill
him out of the woodwork that with him it
wasn't you gotta watch the dot right you
know I'm saying but he's radicalized her
what yeah he did but it was because he
like started get involved with gangs and
he went over there got radicalized and
then his thing was he wasn't high up in
the hierarchy of Isis however organized
they were he was at that high up but he
got attention because he was so he was
like they said he wasn't a killer but
he's like oh if I do this they like me
for this so he just went [ __ ] fool
dumb ass but don't you think that people
who are willing to do that over and over
again ability I feel like they have
something in them that's always been
there that now when given the right
circumstances they can it can come out
so the real person it's like when you
see somebody gets drunk and they're
[ __ ] they're not like that's
actually who you really are
or guy who gets famous they just treats
everyone I can't help them like [ __ ] yes
yes most branch prints um but you are
saying yeah may we're kind of friends
and you know I don't think you're an
[ __ ]
I'm not an [ __ ] thanks buddy you're
successful you are what you eat I guess
but yep I'd like to talk to Matt about
like something has to be done well
tonight can I say this before you come
on I posted because I went on Rogan and
we were talking about the math students
cuz he had Bernie Sanders in and when he
had Bernie smart guy like that I like
that I like that beauty right we were
talking a little bit up here and I said
if Bernie if you if Rome does math
students we've got to have a problem and
if Bernie's what he came up with his
hypothesis I was like yeah I've thought
of that that's not gonna work you got
nothing like no one has a good answer I
was like oh we're [ __ ]
and I said why is it always white dudes
meaning why is always white dudes who
doing the majority of the big mass
shootings not just three or four and so
I was getting [ __ ] for it online I'm
like that's weird and then what hey
Shabbats actually not white do
here's the list they sent me this list
has like all these different colored
guys on it
black white Mexican just a ton of lists
not a ton of white guys like I don't
know 12 I'm like god that's [ __ ]
crazy and they're like you have the
narrative that's the news it's white
dudes blah blah blah and it's [ __ ] up
and this from a black guy and so I
thought it's from white guy so I was
like that is [ __ ] oh I was I was wrong
man I thought was just white dudes doing
this mass shooting I posted it I don't
get involved with this stuff it's not
what I'm about
I liked myeloma dumbass I'm silly I
break down fights I tell jokes that's
why you're not a journalist do you
definitely compose something like this
cuz you've been in the but my point is
is I didn't do any research I just post
that whatever what's just a polarizing
topic especially with your audience you
got it doesn't make political seabright
what got Reich that's a fact
ya know isn't film a dick joke or
something when he's breaking out a
fighter huh slashers Russ and Callen
well but then then people DME friends of
mine cuz like hey brother I I know what
you're saying I'm with you here's the
thing that came from a guy who's mainly
involved with white supremacy might know
mr. Duke blah blah blah it was a
propaganda thing that they posted
that's this isn't actually true like the
FBI came out said and that's actually
not how it is I went you dad
biochip he duped you nobody but a ton of
people sent me that and I was like what
am i doing in post my brother told me
not to I hear you I was like what am i
doing hold it down but it's cool you not
pull it down I went I went listen I'm
out sometimes you gonna do my research
but I think you're also somebody who's
like this sucks in it is putting it
mildly we have a problem like whatever
is going on none of us no matter what
you or where you are on the gun control
debate none of us want to live in a
society where this [ __ ] is every day
educate us man you guys know I can't I'm
not a subject matter semi automatic
automatic
what you're saying automatic and and
they're those type right yeah I have a
gun I don't know what I don't know what
it is yeah and burglar comes in like you
be explain what the difference between
semi-auto semi-automatic which you can
purchase in the United States means
every time you pull the trigger one
round comes out of the barrel
and the most layman's terms possible an
automatic is and so we don't matter it's
adam ak weapons and are yes there was a
weapons know in the 80s they're illegal
so unless they're predated from that
date you you can purchase them as soon
with her the quantity there's like
they're like a hundred thousand dollars
to buy them so you really the markets so
small you can't buy them and then you
cannot purchase one as a civilian you
have to have a celeb so what's a forty
seven that is a semi-automatic rifle
today so when people say well we need a
band semi automatics that that is that's
all that's stupid that's pretty much
they're not saying that they're saying
we have to ban assault rifle weapons
which we did for a while in this country
of 1994 for a decade and all the
research that back that said it didn't
work at all unfortunately so you know
I'm a constitutionalist first everybody
knows that I'm super pro Second
Amendment so in my opinion all of this
it's like we have to have factual
conversations that are based on fact and
they can be rational right we can't like
I think the problem is it's so
polarizing this debate that the left the
right the middle what do we want in the
United States America preservation of
life and the safety for citizens of
course everybody wants that let's start
there yeah but there's certain ways in
my opinion and I don't want to get into
this too much that we can have more
safety with actually empowering our
citizens to protect themselves because
and let me like this is a question I'd
ask for you guys because from my
viewpoint we're having lunch together
later in Santa Monica let's say an
active shooter comes out you guys I'm
carrying whatever I want to carry isn't
that wouldn't you want to have me as a
tool I'll do it and there's a lot of
Americans and well not all not him right
but that's where firearm responsible
firearms should come in straight but you
know I'd say like you have experience so
if there's guys but there's a lot of
guys who aren't veterans who are
military or law enforcement that are
absolutely amazing shots then know how
to carry a firearm and that's to me why
I believe in the Second Amendment
because that you guys are public that
can talk about the exception they well I
might be a little different but there
are a lot of amazing people just
civilians that are shoot better than I
do
let's get one percent I think the guy in
Dayton Ohio was taken down in nine
seconds no 37 by a heroic police officer
that's a
a lot of wives any second yeah actually
30 seconds he killed nine people and
wounded 27 he hit a minute right
maybe but but I know that that that
here's the way I look at it for I own
guns
um and I agree that that I would rather
have you next to me if a bad guy comes
in or crazy guy comes in I don't want to
be a sitting duck I want a gun to shoot
back at I'd rather I'll take my chances
okay I don't know whether or not if
everybody carries guns of homicides go
up if confrontations go up I don't know
I do I do believe that individuals
should have the right to make their own
choices education a lot of times when
you see people are gun people they're
very very aware they're very they're
law-abiding first of all they're they're
super safe with guns they know guns blah
blah blah however there is something to
be said about this we live in a society
where we do have actually very strict
measures against the kind of weaponry
civilians can have no one is basically
allowed to have a machine gun it's
really hard to get a machine gun super
expensive you could shave the pin down
you don't you're doing I mean it's a
major problem
so these killings are not done by a guy
opening up with the news you climb
through and sprang we know they're
they're open with without without with
us em out of it the other thing that you
can't get is explosives you can't get
it's really hard for anybody who's crazy
or anybody who is even connect or even
any videos money to get grenades they I
don't know write that you've got to get
grenades to get actual explosives we
really guard against this which is why
you don't have people detonating
themselves I am sure there are plenty
people if they could learn how to use
you can get I mean the losses so my
Samara thon bombings yeah there's the
some of it but those were those were
used with pressure cookers my point is
this is that it seems to be it seems to
me that legislation is effective and
there has been for ever against certain
weaponry the can't buy a tank can't buy
a missile can't buy a shoulder there we
do have rules we do have sort of
restrictions around Second Amendment
meaning civilians can't have
military-style weapons unless they go
through a shitload of a shitload of
loops I mean like you got to be a prop
master in Hollywood you got it there's a
thousand but just to get a gun in
general it's easier it's easy
yeah so what I'm saying is that it is I
wonder I wonder if if we've said it
seems to me that assault white right
weapons are really unforgiving when they
hit a human body that's a consecrated
conversation here I and I don't I didn't
like read up on anything for I came in
here so I won't speak about that either
dude I just I do want to talk about
dicks later but you know yeah I think
most let's say this map you go on top
see shooting it is a problem but in Neil
deGrasse Tyson post of this terrible
timing and he's kind of a thought but
here's the thing about that is Andrew
Schultz and I were talking about this
this morning on text back and forth he
made a great point because he saw my
post he's like yo you can get [ __ ] for
that Bob and I'm like yeah I know but
the thing is is he goes you know how if
you get rid of everyone's guns or if you
wanna make everything safe if you look
at it and he goes you know there's 250
250 thousand people die a day by the by
cars so do you want make it some some
crazy number that's got to be some
that's worldly I think there's something
like definitely around +30 thousand
deaths a year in the United States from
labels in that but bring that up chin
yeah maybe yeah I don't see anything in
his point he goes if you wanna make
driving safer to get lower deaths let's
wait over the mass shooting you want
everyone drive 10 miles an hour yeah it
was how safe you want to make it or do
you want people to have the the will the
free will to go 65 70 yeah so yeah was
it 40,000 it says yeah roadway yes yeah
and their 4.5 million seriously injured
well that's why you know and it's it's
like you can look point is if you like
if you make it down to 10 miles an hour
you no one's gonna get however like that
yeah have you said no Matt cuz yeah I
don't know if you've been to find the
kid we interrupt non-stop because okay
know when your song about salt weapons I
think that's the really hard part define
assault weapon every States and
federally we look at those completely
different and I think everybody that
doesn't know what a firearm is they're
taking a like a two to three varmint
rifle and they're calling it an assault
rifle it's just really by the appearance
it's not really specified it is some
places but I think that's the problem is
like people that are trying to implement
legislation against the second
don't understand firearms and I think
that's where again you need to have like
rational conversations but then again
what when does it kind of end and I
think that's a lot of us on the pro to a
side is if you keep you know infringing
on the Constitution in the Second
Amendment when does that kind of stop
because yeah we're already at a place
but what you don't want any automatic
weapons well that's all pistols you know
what I'm saying like no here's a
sensible measure what do you do man
there's 400 million guns United States I
don't have the answer I'm not smart
enough but what I'm saying is Bernie
Sanders
well yeah but like putting in emotional
gun control is what I call it and
knee-jerk reactions to tragedies for
you're their own political gain is not
the right answer
like the right answer is starts with the
why like why are we doing this why we
want to save American lives and then it
goes into the how and it actually has to
be tested proven by facts and data but
well how about this idea
the salt weapons ban didn't prove that
what about sensible like here's an idea
that I think is sensible the fact that
you can go into a gun show in Alabama
Vegas or whatever and buy as many guns
as you want right away and you don't
have any background check to my waiting
period and well know if it if you're you
have to purchase through an FFL and you
absolutely have to do paperwork with it
with an idea though so you there is
background checks at gun shows I was
told there wasn't that I I've heard that
I don't I'm gonna sound stupid right now
I'm waiting period to for the license
forgotten forgot to make a transaction
to purchase a firearm you have to go
through an F F yeah even in a gun show
though cuz I was told you buy a bunch of
guns and then people says loopholes but
almost every gun show you can't they're
all FFL dealers and they all have to go
through because I thought it started
with this I thought it started with if I
want to sell Brennan a gun it's my
personal possession I can do that way
here goes B most states do not require a
background check for firing gun shows
from private individuals private
individual law only requires licensed
dealers can conduct riots so you private
individuals a private individual usually
sells the gun though and that kid blows
everybody right then that guy's in
trouble so to me like it gets sticky
because then you have to say Brian you
have your private property I'm not
allowed
a gun to Brennan without a background
check
however I don't think that's a huge
infringement we're talking about a 10
day five day waiting period which I've
already had to do anyway when I bought
my guns I bought it for my license so
that exists in a lot of states yes
already so I wonder though what those
loopholes would it be Ted's it doesn't
seem to be anti Second Amendment to
close those loopholes but it's very
emotion that [ __ ] for people who are
absolutely I all of us agree we don't
want we just don't want to live in
outside of where this shit's going on
but the biggest problems out here logan
brings this [ __ ] up all the time sure
SSRIs like I mean those [ __ ] I like
about Russians I'm talking about I'm
talking about like drugs kids Ron that's
great well no and I think an in part I
truly believe that this is like a mental
health issues problem that is kind of
being shown as a as a gun issue and I
know everybody has their counter points
on the left and right and stuff but like
criminal activity is criminal because
you break the law yeah and we've seen it
where vehicles have slaughtered 30
people driving oh we've seen it in every
format possible so it's kind of like how
do we make American culture a little
more responsible for their personal
safety and what I mean by that it's not
just necessarily carrying a firearm but
hey at risk people like let's let's
activate law enforcement if some kid has
a kill list and his say he's gonna shoot
up the school like let's be proactive
like Ohio it's there's a lot of stuff
and we see similarities across the board
all these people know we do know I don't
know I don't know hi oh his mom two
weeks prior called the police because
she was worried he's gonna do something
[ __ ] the police went and they're not
much they can do that I said convey he's
a big fat loser lives in your basement
what he wants to do he makes threats
he's unread what he wants to do you can
arrest him for being a loser or speaking
his mind we wanted to arrest him for
having Cheetos all over his fingers we
can't even do that you know it's like
what are we supposed to do that's what
you talk about yes are you a puffy
Cheetos guy or a crunchy Cheetos guys
keto bro but I'm your Cheetos [ __ ] I
mean you know 14 days bro you called me
thick you're in shape too though I dude
I got that book to her bond right now a
man is starting away and
I'm going good man yeah it's kicks off
its cause gun control yeah no no see at
least we had a gun posing my beliefs are
on this I don't have a Posie please I'm
just trying reason why I got what we
brought got brought up right away
because you're such like you know your
way around the gun
I mean you're more [ __ ] like you
compared to you and the gun so I want
your perspective on it but usually I
don't like talking about yeah man like
no what are we gonna do I know
great if you came and you drop just this
[ __ ] died piece of a answer like oh
[ __ ] I think it's gonna be a major
political talking point like you know
pop we're gonna have to talk it's an
agenda for them it's a it sorta seem
point they're not trying to tell me
where the politicians rallied around on
either side around essentially did the
community you know the president flew
out there but like immediately we turn
into something for political gain it's
unfortunate and thank you for my sirs
it's [ __ ] hilarious what is sorry
thank you
tell us about that man poke about it's a
it's a memoir of my life you know how I
serve in Special Operations and then as
a contractor in other capacities and
then through all my my business
endeavors so it's kind of this crazy
wild ride and I was it's kind of like a
Deadpool written so I think it's
completely unique perspective to
military culture where from my own
beliefs I've seen a lot of military
books that are hyper dry so they're very
calculated enemy combatant came through
the door training took over to digest -
yeah yeah and and i really wanted mine
to be you're riding shotgun with a young
22 year old ranger fireteam leader who's
having people blow themselves up and
you're having to shoot terrorists in the
face and having like you don't really
necessarily know what to do you can rely
on your training but you're in this so
I'm so in I'm in appreciate it pay us oh
I'm in control no he's [ __ ] yeah man
that's your but do you bring his copies
of the book yeah I brought both you one
[ __ ] yeah I need new and then part of
that like something I've been trying to
change it's kind of like you know the
narrative with veterans I think civilian
culture kind of looks at us as all
victims and I really want to change that
yes there are people with you know
morale grief and pts and that's great
and we're gonna
around organizations that help those
individuals but the large part of the
veteran community is hyper successful we
come from a very diverse background I
have a simple and [ __ ] idiot and I've
somehow become successful you know my
eye out work my intelligence that's
really all I do and I really want people
to see that you can be successful post
military post war and do it over the
[ __ ] you want if you want to paint
pictures being art you want to be a
musician like I've tried it all you know
the only thing is and how I think
similar with athletes to obviously just
way more veterans out there and it's
kind of a sad story but I think football
players or even I don't know how
fighters but especially football players
there's this sad narrative when they're
done with CTE and brain trauma majority
of them don't have brain trauma or CT
you know that I think the statistics are
there they're all right now well idiots
with their money I don't know not Arctic
a lot but the majority the masses the
masses are doing pretty well so it's
same with like yeah that's I think
because I know you
I've been around black rifle and me
we've done our [ __ ] together I don't
view that's like that and I come from a
family Terry family so they boys just
I've always out always hire vets because
the the work ethic like they I and I
have it my experience I'm sure they're
out there I've never met like a lazy
military dude well I'm sure they're out
there trust same but in my experience do
my family through black rifle I've never
met like lazy workers you know like if I
if someone goes and you know you'll jack
him off someone's like go I'm a Navy
SEAL Brian's on it's neat hey you know
pretty hello my name as I get on your
hands are you more of a top or bottom
with us as I present so the way a female
baboon bring up female breath and
present analyze that is that I present
my I present my starfish to him and well
I present my holes and I'm like also I
go and I'm available for cleaning and
cooking so woah respectful do you do
that for Rangers my right
I just said about me Brian's on his
knees here that's how a baboon presents
look there's a blue not huh Ranger on
the left Brian on the right wait what is
that what you were you're a ranger and
then um and then you and they did some
study bro hey my ass a parking goddamn
they say did some stuff why I used to
talk about it but they redacted the
three-letter word out of the book so
whatever yeah so you mean I'm not a cool
guy there's so many more people with
more experience than me in the world I
just wanted it to like a unique
experience and but you are a ranger yes
75th Ranger Regiment and after that defy
the points of them and then
oh wow five mm-hmm [ __ ] their quick ones
you know I'd like 19 months deployed
overseas those but even a little no I'd
love to do it I'd stare at his tattoos
and there's like numbers of bullets next
to them I'd assume what they offer what
didn't he went down so I was looking you
know she [ __ ] remind me right now and
it's a great one it is when I was a
contractor I was in Santa Barbara born
and raised there moved back after the
military and then there was this [ __ ]
chick that I was kind of dating for a
while yeah and big tits hey hey well I
forget I think I'm we're gonna ask man
to be honest with ya let him tell us to
uh sorry keep going though but I'm
talking about the romanization of kind
of veterans sometimes and so I'm I get a
call from my contracting office to go in
this appointment super boring ass
deployment it was in a place that was
super permissive but hey it was gonna be
fun I tell this chick that I'm dating
hey I got it I gotta [ __ ] go in like
two days and she's like yeah you have to
go white were you going I can't talk
about it
Americans can't talk America needs me so
I bounced three [ __ ] days later bin
Laden gets killed the message I got from
that girl I guarantee she masturbated
every single night yeah she wrote me she
was like I know now USA why you had to
leave you and the service for your cup
thank you that's all I happen and then I
was like do I say I'm not a seal and I
definitely didn't kill no yeah I miss
lacy [ __ ] when I go
yeah you're welcome yeah like thank you
for my service because I'm gonna service
you in there look at the Comedy Store
this dude was passing counterfeit bills
this giant guy grabs him throws him on
the ground put some over goes to arrest
him he's out he's out like I'm off duty
cop bouncer at the [ __ ] at the saddle
ranch
yeah and he's kidding hard time I got
give me your [ __ ] hands he says why
does a Rath and they see me what blood
long story short they arrest the guy I
left when the cops came this guy didn't
want to get sued so he goes yeah the guy
from MADtv Bryan Callen the comic was
the one who got him put tied him up and
stuff like that cuz he put so all the
comics were like Bryan did you do karate
thing on this giant do you know the
story yeah and I came back healthy
[ __ ] killer dude that's where I go
dude what the [ __ ] that we heard you did
this jujitsu [ __ ] on this giant black
hood who's passing counterfeit bills had
him on the ground and I would and this
is what I did I went like this I go this
those girls that chase the Special
Forces guys are they called bullet
bunnies bullet blunt that's it that's a
clever one
no like Rangerettes nut bunny that's who
follow lip bunny rangers Rangerettes
Ranger a Leslie dude yes you're more
creative than that that's what that's a
litt bunny oh my god I'm a blood bunny
yeah they have that yeah okay how about
Rachel bunny there's so many bad dad
jokes for that dude you want round your
ammo in me yeah do you want to reload ah
how about a cam oh yes yeah yeah but I'm
gonna treat your dick like a Camelback
that's funny
commando crazy but the last thing I read
about this shameless plug was a
thank-you for my service I really
enjoyed the title cuz I changed it and
it's a funny narrative that I like to
say that I literally got paid paid not a
lot of money paid to go jump out of
planes fast rip out of helicopters with
night vision and shoot the worst
terrorist in the pie in the face so it's
like thank you taxpayers because that
was fun as [ __ ] but you have us both
select skills where no one else can do
it and you're defending our freedom so
there's no there's a lot of badasses
there's so many more passes to me and
they're still doing it so all I am
saluting who do you consider the baddest
sort of dudes in the military
devgru Delta who are the Delta because
I'm partial call them you know Big
Brother but they yeah is that where they
recruit from Rangers mostly or yeah more
than 50% of that units what right you
would have done Ranger so it does I'm at
Matt hey Matt yeah and you tell us tell
me what the dreaded DS about well I play
light in that subject because they're
doing that work yep and there's a Tier
one unit their characters mean it and
they're just absolutely phenomenal the
end of their are they're artisans of war
I mean the the amount of intelligence
and experience I mean some of the guys
you know they did twelve deployments in
battalion and now they're over there
with all the fancy equipment all the
funding when you say over there if I had
a map hey bro everywhere I would assume
hey meadow I don't know if I'm not in
there what Africa's code yeah black ops
yeah that's what I Brennan
if door at 3:00 in the morning it's a
bad day for you yeah no every once in a
while here is dude
I'm just saying dude oh my god they're
not gonna I need or 3:00 in the morning
yeah you're not surrendering it's a bad
day for you know once in a while videos
will get posted and there was one that
happened about two years ago of his a
vehicle interdiction and it was this
high-value target they're going after
and the guys the tier one unit that did
it like within 30 seconds they napped
the dude held him at gunpoint got him in
a van car John have you watched you're
like [ __ ] America don't play around bro
you're like I'm thank god they're on my
team no there's a badass [ __ ]
lit bunny I'm a [ __ ] hero are you a
wise jihadi John and I'm telling it like
this isn't a spoiler it's happened eight
years ago so suck my dick
so jihadi John was like the worst like
just from propaganda he was the face of
Isis killing all the American people
they took I got him I didn't notice I'm
serious so Matt what I was saying yeah
so Ezra howdy John was like the worst of
the worst and then the Americans go oh
you got our attention now you wanna keep
killing our Americans that's cool man
and then they talked to all like the
special for like the intelligence behind
it so they decide to fall him around but
he was very smart
they couldn't track him but they finally
thought they were tracking them falling
him around fall him around and then he
goes to an area where to meet because he
had a family out there and they knew
like the family was his weakness so went
to his family and then from there he
went to go meet with someone but they've
been farmed for like a year now and they
had a drone followed he had no idea for
a year fall and fall and then he went to
this field where he killed a ton of
innocent people and they thought it was
you know it's crazy that that's where he
end up dying because they just hear him
they have like the actual play there
like targets in sight it's jadi john
they hear the guy go and three two one
I'm like what are they gonna do dude and
he holds with his friends if he's just
this the most brutal piece of [ __ ] of
all time what he did to these
journalists and he's innocent people so
I'm like god I [ __ ] hope they skinned
him alive he put he put one journalist
you know he's a pilot
yeah Jordanian pilot put him on I've set
my fire on that cage yeah that all that
so worse person of all time so you want
him to suffer but it's just you have so
much pride man even though it's someone
dying but you realize the horrible
crimes commits and then the intelligence
they have their record net it's gone
three two one I'm like what's happening
right now it's kind of blurry and they
see dude my dick yeah you're 12 I'm a
bullet bunny bro when you sweetie Terris
bullet you see terrorists get [ __ ] in
the ass with a 12-inch hard American
[ __ ] yeah just like and that's a
metaphor not literal American missile if
you know what I mean nah dude those are
bad dudes man I'm I'll be a bullet or
what you were calling bullet bunny hello
bunny I'm into cuz even when I walk
around so my friends are still doing
some really cool [ __ ] I'm always like
hey it's like how's the black ops doing
this guy because I'm [ __ ] washed up
man I'm [ __ ] all I do is be a
douchebag on the internet and write
books apparently now so you're like the
Chuck Liddell special ops yeah yeah well
I'm like Chuck Liddell Tito Ortiz -
right you did not we'll watch I'm not
I'm not through yet
right well we'll watch was like that's
three I'm not quite there
all right but the black ops those are
guys where the government's like hey and
don't worry that's it kind of like no
one says black ops really oh they don't
spec ops black ops Jase ah how's that
fake black up you know JSOC that's great
you're the real direct questions to me
dude would you calm drink how much does
you have about every Dre cups you know
to Ray Kassar joints special that's
God's plan them Operations Command buddy
what is it Janos Tier one there's all
kinds dang though these guys and then
date I may be at your voice just shut up
ask me ask me you know it'd be good for
him I saw his video back in the day I
didn't do it i wish ii did it cuz the
great idea was called tak talk and it
was just people that want to get talk
the operators and you'd call in like a
porn line it's like my ups are so bad
like what kind of gun do you have are
you bristling with exotic weaponry yeah
dude but do you want to go to syria an
exotic trip can you go a long time
without sleep can you live on a cup of
rice live on just your anger that's good
yeah dude you control your breathing
you'd be good at it super well hey but
but the black ops aren't like i don't
how much you can talk about it it just
makes me want to talk about it but the
government doesn't like do you have no
protection right like if you fail the
mission you're [ __ ]
right now no what is that with the
wizard where they go like the movies
it's called the moon yes holy oh holy
hold on Brian we have a real guy here
dude it's all that competitor coffee's
been drinking it's getting to his head -
you okay no not at all I mean the DoD
there's certain risks of course when you
have no ideas hold on what
what's DoD Dogon Department of Defense
boom you're good that's a good one you
wonder how many months they spend with
the DoD
he's 17 is that true 17 months yeah you
have to get it reviewed of course I
don't want any secrets or anything bad
going out those you can't like the Navy
SEAL guys like they all couldn't write
books right who killed Osama bin Laden
well now Rob O'Neil wrote here no but
they operated away like certain details
right and if the I did a very
[ __ ] on ya one guy didn't get it
approved by the DoD and gotten massive
amounts of trouble that's what I'm refer
to many told me that Darryl is zero dark
watch my favorite movie now hold on when
you watch it oh that's how we do it and
then I heard that the guys who are the
advisors to Kathryn Bigelow and the
writers gave them a bill of goods
basically [ __ ] of they gave him a
fake narrative cuz that's not how it
happened well you sound like you got
damn cool movies or movies they're never
well you sound like a communist oh you
do sila [ __ ] why I said you know movie
yeah it's great that's how it happened
it is though no believe it or not
believe it or not they actually gave
them the wrong they gave my it's a great
story not how it happened I think you're
full of [ __ ] I've seen sniper hold on me
check with Matt hey Matt I don't know
you can't guess we just did see what he
just did
classic [ __ ] affirmation by Delano
bleed to Brendan's right well there you
go you see what he did he went like this
when a guy goes I don't know watch this
ask me what I do in the military ask me
what would you do the military this and
that he asked me if I ever took a life
amen
here we kill anybody over there never
stopped to look brother you've got all
the raises doing my job yeah now as
she's a job to me only now ask me
seriously what did you do in the
military seriously bro would you do over
there you wake up for every morning yeah
you're welcome
that's bear oh [ __ ] how would it like
that was straight your welcome for my
service yeah yeah thank you for my
service that's okay you can say it's a
great title of a book thank you
your you have always had a great sense
of humor appreciate that you sell art
dude seriously [ __ ] man life's a crazy
when you get hit by a bus tomorrow the
fact I'm alive is a miracle and I do
every morning I [ __ ] love this show I
like to immediately I knew you were a
real dude because the first time I met
you I started asking you about [ __ ] and
you go look i'm a i-i-i-i did compared
them a lot of guys I did nothing I'm a
huge [ __ ] and you just were so
self-deprecating and welcome he's that
guy who and welcome he's you did I meet
you through Brennan shot great no I
think the first time we all met was on
the set of range 15 and then we did the
podcast together and then
no I don't worry anyway you got mama D
show will afford race they've - how many
tell me you made range 15 yes we went it
just I would definitely want it done
yeah yeah I forget I forget but all that
matters is now that were in the same
room lor maybe four I'd mail because I'm
a bullet bunny whoo you're like this is
good the bullet bunny let's make a tee
shot dude we gotta make t-shirts and
just give all the proceeds in the
military all right
bullet Bonnie we're gonna get some
people doesn't need any money well give
it to like maybe veterans are some not
the military right just we do D we do
that every day blast rifle sure bullet
bunny would you guys just don't you guys
give proceeds Rankin a lot you do that
cool hey man you're like North Korea
right now we're gonna meeting here
trying to find he's out yet confident
you're a [ __ ] communist dude you told
me I get on my knees first of all Ferb
Navy SEALs but now you're calling me a
communist I can't win I like that you
know of the lingo and I don't yeah he's
got it down I got you know you should be
like an honorary you know it is I'm a
people you know I want it like that I
went to San Antonio with these guys to
fire guns I've never and I don't know if
I told you so no if it's on the video we
post a video of it you know me dink grew
up around gun it's not really familiar
with them I have them because robbers
come my [ __ ] boom boom boom shotgun
don't come my [ __ ] out yeah but I
shoot guns with them dude I was I was
scared like straight-up scared life
United John's I was shooting yeah yeah
why did I have you to 500 Magnum which
is one of the biggest pistols out one
hand it's good oh you may end up in
death row you go that's not what it was
no it was essentially the same but at
500 a little more I don't know yeah come
on it's like like Brendan is such a big
strong dude that that if you got him
going
he just need he'd need some [ __ ] and he
would be he'd be a killer he wasn't bad
after a couple reason that they use
missions on but I you and I don't like
sound like that's such a bunny right now
yeah you don't like those loud noise
like my back hurts like I it's like oh
no [ __ ] [ __ ] injury again I'm not
used to him it might maybe someone feel
the same way the first time I went to
UFC it was so like just like you realize
it's violent and it's great how see how
good they are at it and I've seen he's a
badass but when I was shooting I was
like the like I can't imagine man
pointing this at another humor
being it was insane and when they're
pointing one back at you do you want to
have one yeah I'm not made for that life
Roger hey you know I want to be a Navy
SEAL ones in high school really oh yeah
really yeah football didn't work out I
want Dan oh you would had the looks I
mean you would have to lean out a little
bit right now bro kind of a giant for
Delta another six more what dude some of
the most toughest badasses I've ever met
are like five six in a book like Sadie
yeah and they're just like little
machines and they're running I hear you
short people rule I hear you the thing
is you would break down pride because
your feet and stuff all Papa can run I
cannot look everybody you know you're
very strong but yeah I can definitely
run the longest name no no no doubt I
wonder though over a long and papas in
shape it 230 Navy SEAL xxx I would never
physically I would never bet against you
you're stronger than everybody he's
stronger than everybody you think you
know strong he's stronger than everybody
I don't know about Lauren Lando he
[ __ ] did a farmer's carry with a
hundred pounds in each hand [ __ ] got
carried at six minutes Wow
he did after she did not Ronco not a big
Turkish getup with with 145 where he was
lying down and then he put more weight
on it I think you put what what I mean
that's crazy yeah that's strong that's
that core strength yeah I watch this
[ __ ] dudette bedless with 600 pounds
he was doing reps the 10 cents what he
was complimentary now he's sucking you
off it's great no you were saying I was
sucking you off because and don't make
your dick that you thought of me isn't
it don't make your dick don't go don't
do that you don't don't hold your dick
like that don't do that [ __ ] like that's
like we're watching black yeah that's
not if we're [ __ ] to like it's like
he's a footlong sub
yeah it's true those pornos grossed me
out cuz I'm like my dick looks nothing
like now I know but I did read a thing
where excited
I think we're Navy SEALs oh I don't know
why I'm so into this idea you're like
Jesus Christ
let's talk about anything but the
military but I did read where they were
recruiting more guys who were bigger
athletic like the the the height
standard went up recently it was like
six three six yards there's no height
standard it's just not a sneaker
athletic guys were getting more into it
and out of like whatever their crop they
had they were a taller than more
athletic than usual all that cold is
what [ __ ] a lot of Navy guys were
trying to be SEALs well swimming really
that's the one they I'll give it to
seals man those those dudes know how to
swim you say swim yeah good
not me that's why I ever joined Ranger
time yeah I'm not swimmer no you want
you want me to frog it up yeah that's
what I'm doing I don't think you can ask
me what I'm doing I have a perfect idea
here we go Brian this is the idea what
we're gonna do I'll call in some favors
and I'll get Brendan to go through buds
so he can increase his career as an
entertainer having that little buds
check mark that's a good you not the
serve you just go through all of buds
and then maybe just how weak I'm sure
the seals would let you go through he'll
say no more fam yeah you do it you don't
see yeah yeah give me a heads-up though
okay I need I'm like signals get texted
okay six months are you in shape for
buds you know so just Tim Kenny I'll sum
about how I wanna be waterboarded I
always make the joke and someone sent it
to him
you know Tim's on my buddy and I was in
Austin and he tweet out shop where he
heard you were looking to get
waterboarded me my boys are out and you
know I go i but haha crazy he goes no
for reals just send me an address cuz I
was in town doing comedy he's like send
me your address we'll make it happen we
can film and with it I was like oh well
no Tim I I wanted to try it
he waterboarded themselves you see that
yes I love Tim he's a crazy bastard talk
about a dangerous person yeah you kind
of lose everywhere with him we talked
about another guy who's kicking ass
outside of the military
yeah man of course he is super awesome
he did that we were at up it on it I'm
an Arby's place and we walked I walked
in with my wife and he looked he looked
at my wife it was like man you're really
gorgeous in real life some people don't
look that good in real life and I was
like I will shoot oh that's like man
that's just hard either way it's gonna
be shitty and beat my ass
he's remarkably well like he's just he's
such a good dude he's just such a nice
got a great Suwanee [ __ ] dude and at
the same time he's he's the you and him
should do a podcast and take over the
world yes there's both funny man that's
true appreciate it you guys are both
that would be a good podcast out what
the best podcast ever yeah I don't even
podcast anymore so you know rarity I
guess that all anymore he's so why not
also why is he so shredded I don't know
all right there's a few people when
everyone goes everyone's on peds and
like I hear you but him
no cuz he's already for a USC I think if
they were like hey you got a you know a
title fight he would jump right back in
and do it I know he's somewhat retired
but he's such a [ __ ] beast look I so
cheesy
so not your dad this whole entire
episode has us been man lusting over
special-operations dudes we went through
the seals now rod Tim Kennedy we
apologize sorry dude um I'm super crunk
about your book though how I have the
book tour has been a lot of prose I
assume I actually haven't done the
physical book towards the signing yet
those are coming up next week so I've
just been doing a lot of media but I've
done so many events over the last six
years of my have you been doing them for
that do you hired up like a press well
I'm a slice I'm singling Random House so
they've been doing all their stuff and
then I have an internal PR person
through black rifle and I am a marketing
my brain I got yeah co-founder Wow it's
doing really well yeah we're doing we're
doing well fee on the planet bro it is a
brown roses yeah it's it's it's a it's a
really special thing and to see the
community kind of rally around you who
did you start with Evan haver
he's the he's the founder and then I
came in Evan what is what Evan was a
military guy to get former Green Beret
and he was a CIA contractor for a long
time and kind of met him through what
does that mean the CIA contractor was
that mean let's talk about more military
yeah you can tell you that you know what
I said you know what this is like and I
feel bad for that it's okay it's like
dry guachos and people I only have some
about five so do you think McGregor is
gonna fight again [ __ ] with you let me
shut down you know I use like dude no
it's okay Evans Evans a badass man he's
a he's like a angry little hipster dude
but his chick in the middle there
my dudes from that's on sale yeah I said
his chick yeah he's all that best is a
dime piece so I expect him to be married
to a dime piece yeah those dogs I love
those Australian Cattle Dogs just life I
love those you're gay no I won't want to
so badly you're out of the [ __ ] bed
but I I want one of those those
available sure
we had a [ __ ] man we have so many dogs
at the office and heavy yeah we had this
gentleman some of these actually I think
we're gonna have these dogs behind her
office and then ended up lying and
saying oh we came to give him away so
all of our customer service department
IT department adopted like six dogs I'm
talking to myself no because I go I go
with those do-over you guys I grew up
with them now they're cutest [ __ ] yeah
smart cute but there's so he's Mark you
that [ __ ] on Instagram the youtuber
that got caught like she was ever here i
watch that this morning did that not
piss you off what happened like Walter
Reed dark enough I was gonna well you're
like now you can hit [ __ ] puppies and
you're gonna put that [ __ ] in my face
that [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz I know you gotta
like work working dogs and stuff but you
could tell that was just our being at
snot octane and Doc [ __ ]
yo dude she's like eating that thing
Lena's [ __ ] holes what was she famous
for sucking [ __ ] and then she puts on
there she puts on there she's like
thanks for everyone showing the real
support see everyone can have a bad day
I'm like bad day I've had some bad days
[ __ ] I've never hit a dog because of it
now so watch this watch this
on the door she thought this would be
edited out yeah I don't you want to
watch this does that a bunch and then
spits in the dog's face it's disgusting
just so don't watch you guys watching I
think she's just frustrated with the dog
yeah but you don't do that oh no no keep
playing hold on I can't have one
defender 34 million views I turn it off
this season worse or what well you just
have to see why you should be upset
those other ones like all right they're
not great but
the dog is kind of an ogre is playing
with it yes here's what geez I want to
be famous in YouTube I'm kind of get my
views up you [ __ ] hound I think this
is part of the problem right now is
everybody with their little challenge
channels and their little influence they
think that they're so [ __ ] important
you're like you're nobody that's just
putting out some tongue like just like
me I'm a [ __ ] nobody well stop
thinking you're so [ __ ] Horton
why not no one's that important no in
the grand scheme psyching ricky gervais
is this tree people kindness man laughs
and comments all you got do to be happy
would shoot us nuts laughing come you
don't I'm talking about
it's like Jerry Seinfeld and communed
getting cards he a man who's our st.
Ricky Gervais is they were talking about
how Seinfeld goes I can't stand when
someone comes up to me and tells me a
joke tries to be funny
makes insulting I've worked on this
graph for this many years like it's
insulting Ricky Gervais skills I finally
in daring like they're trying to relate
to make it funny and Jerry goes now if
they're [ __ ]
and then Ricky Gervais went we're not
that important dude we're really not
that important what are you talking
about there's a great point he's like no
we're not that important like it's not
that big of a deal no it's not that
backs rocks anything that's not have to
call you out is I didn't like how you
weren't that upset at that video and I
feel sorry for your dogs yeah I hit
might know I was like I call I always I
always when I see that I always like I'm
always like she got really she might
have had a reaction like girlfriend
because that dog might have been like I
don't know yeah he's been offender
should meet a new dog you an offender no
she seems like she doesn't know anything
I'm at best getting finish the video
yeah people wanna have dogs what people
like that shouldn't have dogs they don't
have cats I'm kidding kidding
but they're so frail he can't hit a cat
you know dude a cat will [ __ ] you up to
my buddy just got his whole face ripped
up by his cat it was just chilling on
his shoulder it's like some [ __ ]
oh dude everywhere it with a ear laid
open you needed stitches after 10 it's
like little little bitty cat I think
well Yahoo I would do to your face dude
what is that the last ever the show we
talked about what animal would be the
worst to die by for at the fact that I
say not so good did I say yeah guar with
the yog WA the Aqua is the big spotted
Castle known as a leopard that living in
the Amazon you know for most in South
America okay but there are sometimes the
male's can be you know 300 pounds they I
killed no consortium humans or no they
cease they are not they are not afraid
of humans because for many reasons but
they will kill you Russia Kim well I
started out this you know I thought
you're from Argentina yeah could be it
could be I could be you know I don't
know no we're talking about cats dogs
hitting dogs oh that's right in the face
yeah get a big cat if you push him
around that was the point
but um you guys are in San Antonio now
do you love it out there
I do yeah I live in a quiet little town
called brain tech I don't like San
Antonio your address what what it is
Isis it is not not Austin uh I'm kind of
in between Austin and San Antonio move
be it's the move Austin too crowded too
many hipsters too many [ __ ] cutoff
jean shorts no I'm straight I'm straight
[ __ ] hillbilly I mean I live on quite
a few acres I got you know I built a
home gym out there I got like my little
ATV pragma no I'm just saying this way
always because people look at it be like
oh this goes a rich [ __ ] house what I
bought out there would buy you probably
a one-bedroom studio here and like LA or
San how I have for something so and I
live off [ __ ] rainwater I don't even
have a well I don't have city water so
I'm [ __ ] he's boning it it's great I
love Santa where they're at I love Santa
they have the best hotel they're the
best I've ever said what's called the
Pearl the Pearl is that true it's it's
an rola borough Civ what that's where I
stayed it sound boil is that what you're
saying some Antonio San Antonio
something what would what he used to be
it looks like it's straight out of the
Wild West it was an old it was an old
brewery and someone came and bought it
and said they were gonna gentrify the
area everybody called him an idiot
boom the parol the it's a whole area
over it's the hotel Emma my name style
lab so it's called the hotel Emma and
it's no sigh inside shows in San Antonio
jeez I'm doing San Antonio hey could you
guys are there because this hotel it is
the [ __ ] investment it's legit
they pour cement on your beds that are
like the home cook they got a gangster
coffee shop that haunted but it's
[ __ ] by the way right now where you
are it is it is simply 105 degrees at
least correct yeah and and I came here
to California thinking y'all are gonna
give me some good weather
and it's like [ __ ] 95 degrees here
yeah but you by the ocean baby
Santa is so hot I panicked I walked
outside to go we're gonna go I'm walking
to the Starbucks she goes no you're not
oh yeah I do well in the heat no it's
not that
turned back around no stockist in
Houston I got I got caught in the locust
storm
really yeah I made my show i locusts for
landing I mean women were screaming
because this was probably [ __ ] five and
there's just locally and and locusts
started landing on one man and on my
jeez a gorilla show girls my god they
were flying around I was like well
they're a locust
I read you that that should have whipped
out that a guy that did the
counterfeit-money kung fu and just [ __ ]
those locusts up can I be honest with
you yeah I did the delivery on your kill
lines are great I know I did I did I
love it there's no you know Jay's
working at Houston right now oh yes yeah
he said he wanted to hang himself
oh yeah he went outside during the
little summer too much simply too much
cuz humid cuz humid I'm there next month
bro what do you guys up to I know you're
still touring I actually looked up to
see if you had a comedy show I was in
town not the case wait that's you hold
on I'm doing it when I leave tomorrow
man I guess showed Saturday night damn
and are you touring I'm shooting a show
right now schooled on ABC that's right
yes how's it going it's good it's just
I'm there all day what season this is
the second season how big are you [ __ ]
sorry I thought was it starting off
questions Brad well now question dude
you got lost in my mind yeah
yeah yeah I pulled that GPS out that's
gonna say that GPS of love hey say so
you've done the book what's next dude
what else is there for you to do your
thought about that like what's the
what's the endgame here there's this the
other day
you see I plan the journey towards a
goal and the journeys what's fun for me
I read that Pinterest is more you know I
got you know that's a mileage this is
gonna be you it really depends on how
well this thing does I mean the pre
sells are kicking well and again thank
you to everybody that supported me but I
have a really cool project in the works
right now that no one knows about that
I'm working on because that exact
question when this comes out people like
what's Matt gonna do next I'm spec wow
you can kind of act by that's what's
good about you is you I'm gonna do a
full feature myself it should be yeah
good because I was thinking about it and
I won't give anything away but you know
I feel like I'm a script to screen kind
of guy and I've been directing and I
edit and I all that stuff and I have an
amazing team and my buddy Eli and I are
working this really [ __ ] cool project
and we're gonna shoot it straight
gangster style so if you'd be meeting
like actors hey any day of the week you
were always range 15 we stole the scene
yeah but it's gonna be like a real movie
I love range 15 it was great at the time
bro we're real actors these are like a
real movie you guys were great and you
ad-lib that uh this gate doesn't this
gates broken or new gate or something
that whatever I'm just what we do dude
yeah we do improve letter G in it though
man okay he wants wait a second where is
there is if there is a fake gay porn
scene in here I'm not gonna give too
much away there's actually no sex you
guys would just need to act like you
were narrating like a porn would you be
I agree but yeah sure it's in a very
reverent way I'm not like let me I get
to present Shh what's that yeah so my
team the stripper salmon are fish that
would be really funny I'll tell you
about this scene after after so that's
the plan though huh yeah I don't know
keep crushing it man I really just want
to have black rifle everywhere in
America and we're working on the
franchise program still in the
brick-and-mortar retail role out in 2020
so just really focusing on the company
guys we're doing uh not a
brick-and-mortar was almost like a
coffee truck right in Vegas it's like a
it was
for a little bit we have an LM TV which
is a light medium tactical vehicle which
is like a big old truck in the military
and we turn that into a mobile coffee
shop which is [ __ ] awesome but we
have about five coffee shops open now
and we're doing a test for an Chai's
with a really cool partner and then once
that goes where I start hopefully
opening up stores with some epic people
would you say coffee a lot of times
we'll have coffee at these designer
coffee shops and it's sour because they
don't roast the bean enough yeah could
be under roasted or they can just get
you know some some of those weird
Ethiopian one sour sour it's like I like
it you like it salad you like not sour
but some of the Ethiopians that are
roasted properly the roasts are probably
you Devon does he's so gangster I mean I
know you guys are roasted that the black
rifle I think roasts about coffee a
little longer than a lot of other
coffees everything from light are very
dark Chuck why should his dog you like
it di yours is really are the darkness
you want the dark like I like a little
dark I mean I like my Pete's like you
know but black rifle thanks for sending
me no black rifle coffee by the way you
just literally have to text me your
address and I will get you a coffee club
subscription for free which is sends it
straight to your door every everybody
knows yeah we can do big brown let me
know little s coffees on me dude alright
appreciate you look there's my wife and
I with meat in her hands just randomly
dude I you guys are crazy
yeah how did you meet your wife I was
telling how you guys need to do less
doctor yeah he tracked her down for sure
I did um yes she is gorgeous good for II
meant fantastic but you get GD is that
what movie is that I think just like
Matt best dude she's got she got a
trainer now and we had the home gym and
she [ __ ] puts in like two hours a day
just killing it and making me feel like
a fat lazy [ __ ] but she's killing the
girl chested son of a [ __ ] with tattoos
I'll just kill all they got some war
scars on you yeah but I can't show you
got some warm because they're not
visible oh they're on the inside of his
brain inside of my skull
yeah if you know what be dope if they
the such a random thought but if they
could do like with how they say they
could begin the eventually technology
middle of download
yet the memories in your brain if I
could just download Matt best brain and
go through like the tours
that'd be so sick man I thought you're
gonna say go through the Sexy's head
oh that's who even think about that
that's his wife's I'm a [ __ ] I'm saying
no take it back three years so like
three wife whatever that coming too yes
yeah we're do heating if you went to the
bullet Bunny's there's just a ton I got
a lot of dogs on your circle on here and
I'd like I need myself for working
shepherds and Australian Cattle Dog and
even that de sure hey is the video on
here where they [ __ ] blow up with you
blew up Prius we know we put a mini gun
on a Prius but actually here it go if
you don't mind go to my wife's to her
handles like Noelle best just click on
that and then find it and I want to show
Brian our American Shepherd that we have
he's like the cutest [ __ ] on the
right yeah definitely don't do that for
me that's what is that oh it's an entire
bird so it's real it's an Australian
Shepherd but it's a mini so it he'll be
around 30 pounds full-grown but yeah I
don't care people call my wife she's
smart beautiful talented so hey I don't
care yeah well I'm just no she's married
to me and I'll [ __ ] be looking
anything it's hard not look at you in
the background I know
look at you as a background like what
problem you guys look like you have fun
man you guys have kids you're like
firing guns we got done like a man you
should have kids just was like well hold
off and be quick on 32 she's 26
we got a good time world you're 32 yeah
I am your success and helpful piss and
vinegar right [ __ ] 32 men
I'm you're 20 years younger than I and
already wealthy you're welcome I'm not I
mean what if I told you this Brian money
doesn't make you wealthy Yeah right
that's what's in here you're [ __ ]
right and in here no I'm really careful
okay I made the [ __ ] up
I've not had a lot of coffee god you're
a [ __ ] huh you can't run with the
Wolves dude you're I wanna let me run
with you guys
sure Oh
let me see your best wolf howl watch my
ready go what's here that's like Celine
Dion animal
hold for a while performing singing
lessons geez now you [ __ ] try that
because that's not a wolf sky be more
like it a little that's a [ __ ] coyote
that ain't a [ __ ] wolf can I get my
dog to give me a [ __ ] wolf howl man
no not a wolf but it gave me a dog barks
let's seize God they're done no like dog
man that's still a dog see you wolf howl
bro stop see you wolf oh come on his was
good
yours is very something very strange
miss cut did very strange is long what
would be your guys's random question I'm
just [ __ ] Katherine events what would
be your swan song meaning you got one
day to live what would he play in all
day or an album about this album now
[ __ ] albums was it 1994 it has to be one
BP dude how can one song mine would
either be got its stuff I'm really into
Dave Matthews right now so else yeah I
love you know I'd rather not hard enough
for you bro home what do you hate right
his real penis what you don't like Dave
Matthews at all nah you don't celebrate
his Callaghan in the least bit
no not Dave life nah huh Wow what do you
what kind of music you like good music
what would be a song to ride off into
the hurricane like like you know you'd
like you're gonna ride into the point of
the Strayer not come back a child is a
good right call
voodoo - how are lil wing by Stevie Ray
Vaughan which is my all-time favorite
song can you play it for me real quick
Jenna have no idea what he's referring
hooters can you travel
well outstanding that's - a mountain top
down with the edge - ding ding
you won't listen Dave man yeah the
problem is you don't even know that song
yeah I can play this this is Jimi
Hendrix we'll watch him watch you see
watching what's it legend helicopter
crash yeah and watch this [ __ ]
like I'm just ready to blow [ __ ] up
right now God dude would you everybody
here knocked out or someone's getting
come in like that's where this song is
taking right now he's the whole reason I
started playing guitar oh you can play
the guitar play for about 15 years yeah
Wow he's amazing
yeah you gotta get some of this going in
your iPods man yeah no probs it bro oh
you know what I said yeah you know
what's cool though let's Gillis this and
then I can also crash into me with Dave
Matthews that's fine I don't like are
you hating on Dave dude gonna be honest
bro what else besides [ __ ] Stevie Ray
Vaughan we can have difference of
opinions we've shown that twice in this
podcast it's the right friends a bullet
bunny
I like everything be honest yeah I go
from like NS new album do that sick love
it yeah I'm like I go from like hip hop
to rock - brutal metal - likes me I'd
sit in my sauna after my workout every
day and I list put on like Spanish music
what's his name whatever it's like mmm
okay it's fun well that--okay me Ahmad
okay just like that dude damn dude I'm
not mad at that voice yeah we come out
in music videos all the time the last
one we launched a month ago it was
called can't believe we miss this when
we find a 9 in the world and rock and
roll in the charts in a day well goddamn
that you were writing and playing music
the last music song that we came out
called yeah he write simple ya writin
played music good I started everything
about from type in I can't believe we
missed this
hey get ready to be judged by chin over
here it's like American [ __ ] Idol he
judges every song this is a song it was
kind of like for athletes and military
oh wow
he's a Korean [ __ ] Simon Cowell we
miss all the good days and it's an 80s
joke ballad oh it's a joke man yeah yeah
cuz it's about missing the military and
all the dumb [ __ ] we did in it you know
and we went real sensual on it as you
can
[Music]
this is you say yeah that's me saying
wow Jared's way better than me I just I
fake it til I miss you can sing too dude
he's got an elf [ __ ] legendary voice
well legendary it take it easy dude he's
first can we see here this sings the
national anthem at events he did at the
Texas Motor Speedway in front of like
20,000 people [ __ ] erupted I was so
I'm so [ __ ] proud of him for it
though can you fast-forward to the end
like where you see the slap right there
little before that little spore that
right there right oh he can sing bleuer
yeah right there so great check this out
dude this I harnessed my inner I know
yeah it's my inner slider my Joanne [ __ ]
that play yeah nice good guy that's you
yeah I trying to be slash this thing is
anyways you guys are a couple of silly
geese yep you have to watch anymore so
I'll do I love it where can I wear what
else can we see did it went well right
yeah that I think got like a million on
Facebook and a little bit on here so we
do we do pretty well in the YouTube
channel always [ __ ] doing crazy [ __ ]
what's one more we can see I'm super
into this like how do you do this like
why is it cute dear it's good people so
that's who you started this with okay
why do you keep going down I'm a knuckle
dragger you want to fix it for me I'll
fix it
yeah we want music Brandon what you want
yeah I want to see what give me your bed
give me another one my toilet bunny up
huh dude he's multi-talent you [ __ ]
this bullet oh wow sorry dude I told you
I could said earlier I'm sorry
you know his other his other boy things
like a goddamn angel no I didn't know
that Jared Tara's not the kind of guy
you think would sing like that
he is he's crazy talented he's like yeah
yeah he's still doing great bros Rawson
yeah I saw him he came to my show in
Salt Lake yeah he was there yeah that's
great what song we should bring up um
let's see we can do is bro
[ __ ] I operate that's funny this is the
first like high school i op and if you
want to know what a bullet bunny is this
is this is something when they say
operator what do you mean by operator
well that's the whole play on it cuz
operator was coined a word to your 1.2
million views good Brian the workshop
you look at that girl
catchy that's Harley Lots she is on it
and call it easy on the eyes what does
she do she was just a friend of ours
that we did content with it was just an
intro but I was making fun of rap so I
was like dude I'll just do a rap song
myself oh [ __ ] that's Rocco yeah you
know him right yeah we know Robert I
managed to get on the mines he's on the
mines now kicking ass Haney is this
wrong like The History Channel just yeah
something she's a great guy
we do dumb [ __ ] like this all the time
and this song I believe was at 12 in the
world on the billboards all genres just
before your with your girl yeah yeah
this is probably the biggest song we've
ever done on the floor 3.2 million views
well now it's got way more on Facebook
when you play with live says you wrote
all this mm-hmm look I'm at Fox found
zero [ __ ] just making fun of like the
tactical industry now everybody was he
really singing that yeah Rocco can sing
too it's like weird when all of her
friends suck is happening with you guys
then we're all kind of failed musicians
he used to sing as a kid and I used to
play guitar as a kid doesn't an emo band
a blind story
[Music]
this is fancy [ __ ] hell is this not
fun to watch so memory timeout ball
bunnies we call them gun bunnies in the
in the Cowboys Alma gun bunny yeah and I
make this little one right here it's a
dude but just doesn't roll off your
tongue like a bullet bunnies okay yeah
the two bees so sweet there you go for
app music from I'm glad you're engaged
in this I know I'm like dis ELISA I mean
you can use it it's my youtube so yeah
you guys just came in second place no
active Dave Matthews you guys we did a
song called [ __ ] Isis once each I up
because of that real and then we'll get
out don't go to current events good just
give me one more chin I'm so much fun
[ __ ] I said yeah that's [ __ ]
hilarious and that's it million views by
that fast-forward it cuz it's a little
less roseola once you start seeing right
there and obviously with my my better
half right there
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
ghost ride that hum be like a whip
renewed
I'm sure I see something oh yeah I get
death threats all the time really yeah
from ice again that's why I need an AR
cuz I have night vision and an AR by my
bed because I gotta protect myself
[Music]
yeah we don't take it easy those are the
only ones in the world who could pull
this off
better Tim Tim Davis continues home at
crazy bastard yeah I gave his home he's
crazy so obviously we're a very
irreverent in her content so sorry if
it's offensive it's pretty much the same
thing from here on out I'm comfortable
watching your [ __ ] yeah I'm not a huge
like it's like very like a real
narcissistic treat another one play
nothing song about people it goes like
this you guys guys guys guys
you got to keep it down I really
appreciate it if you'd listened to the
words this song oh she starts and I was
like this is the [ __ ] where was this at
like you're speaking it was just I'm
shitty have some shitty they were mixing
comedy and music one guy
let's go to Colonel Vette look man if
you need red wine at 4:00 p.m. if you
need sushi at 9:00 p.m. if you need
breakfast at 6:00 a.m.
whatever you need posts mates has got it
I forget about this agreement that I can
call and have it delivered to me here's
the thing I gotta go to the store no no
just have it to live or at least a
called cuz you're old and I'm younger so
I think I post mates and you don't know
call because you're seven you know bombs
are your fears you don't call anybody to
talk to you know do you have the app on
your phone you hit whatever you want it
gets delivered to me under an hour and
it's 24 hours a day 365 days a year
postmates sprays within the a dude and
for a limited time only post mates is
given the fine kid Lister's
$100 a free delivery credit for your
first seven days that's actually a lot
of money to start your free deliveries
down low
the app use the code bucks the fighter
again the codes the fighter for $100 of
free delivery credit for your first
seven days when you download the post
mates app anything you need anytime you
need it definitely don't call post mates
it download the post mates and save with
the code
don't call post mates the five mates no
one's gonna answer if you call the post
mate post mates promo code the fighter
sleep and exercise two very important
things sleep and exercise but it's Avery
was tracking your sleep who's tracking
how well your workouts are doing for
your body but your heart rate or putting
on about your heart heart and everything
else who's tracking that I'll tell you
how many hours of actual sleep you get
I'll tell you is go ahead tell Matt
whoop oh whoo there it is WH oo P the
strap you put it on you wear 24/7 and
measure your heart rate 100 times per
second 24/7 I swim in mine it's easy to
charge a trash or recovery but her
ability yeah resting heart rate
everything and it gets detailed man with
your recovery if you're sure right well
I told you guys this I was riding a bike
thoughts burn all these calories it told
me I was burning this many loop really
got down to the nitty-gritty when he
actually was off by 400 calories at
least it was like you're burning this
many because it tracks your heart rate
resting heart rate your max heart rate
per second everything but also detract
your couch throughout the day just
living breathing walking you're burning
calories this tracks it your sleep is
Lauren asleep yeah but even to sleep
cycles it measures your REM sleep your
deep sleep in your light sleep yes just
he'll wake up through the night it's
fantastic and and it what I dig about it
too is it has a five-day battery life
I'm in charge mine yet I've had it way
long in five days has a live heart rate
monitoring it has a dope band so it
looks cool the connects your phone
bluetooth you can track it whenever you
want
I'm telling you man all you got to do
you subscribe to whoop you download the
app it's a monthly subscription
nothing will give you more detailed
about living a healthy life to the
fullest if you a keto kid this is super
important
I've been on it and I swear by these
freaking things I swear by him so right
now just go to whoop calm that's wh 0p
calm use the code fighter for 30 hours
off a woo membership and enjoy getting a
shred city with your boy population 1
look guys you're looking at me right now
if you're watching this and you see you
see the glow you see how young I look I
don't age dude I get back to the 7
they're like Brian what them how the
[ __ ] you look so young well I don't know
it's called on it dude
I got all my nutritional optimizing
potions I need yeah and Judes real
emotions how do you think Brian
remembers the script he's on alpha brain
that's reactor right guys my dad that's
my why is my breath smell so damn good
got health cuz your guts right man's
right and they just sent me my battle
ropes cuz you know me I'm the keto kid
now I'm down some weight but I need on
its help they got everything
ropes a keto kid yep I got the battle
ropes gets red city population me and
you guys we got joint oil glutamine
creatine electrolytes the total Kido
baby baby assaulted Waterman watermelon
I use melatonin spray how about there so
nutrients whatever you need man Kido
kids let's take it by the horn if you
down the street a credit you ever done
the shrimp tech hell yeah I've done the
SH I swear to God I swear to God the
shroom tech I take that [ __ ] and I'm
like why after my work and I'm like why
am I still have I have crazy energy that
[ __ ] is the best thing I've ever taken
that stuff makes me crazy shroom tech
mmm I take you out for brain I feel like
I ran out of my shrimp to feel like Elon
Musk go to on it calm slash fighter and
get temperature off the entire dam site
from supplements to workout gear
everything jump on board right now it's
on it calm slash fighter you're welcome
my heart is broken and it bleeds but for
music all the time man model god that's
I will I'm in yeah right what is this
so Victoria Secret casts its first
openly transgender model
last year the
I believe he was a CEO at Victoria's
Secret but he runs the parent company
his name is Edie
Razzaq he said that transgenders
wouldn't be in the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show because it was a fantasy
and he didn't think transgenders could
sell that fantasy so I got a lot of
backlash about it he then issued an
apology at her yes that's her bro I
might be in odd-eyed [ __ ] I would
make I would make out with her right now
are you talking Pirlo stop there here I
don't go stop this is post-op I was just
curious what we're working with he too
like same question so my girl tried
honey dick yesterday she sends me the
picture and she goes babe do you think
she's hot I go first of all it's a
[ __ ] I'd [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of my she's
right
yeah the thing's hot okay as in like
listen that's not that's not pretty it's
like when I went to Thailand I saw baby
boys there I was with Brody Stephens the
late Brody Stephens and Zach everybody
were like I was like I said she was
stroking zip Brody's face I go it was
Brody if you had sex with that girl if
you had sex with that [ __ ] you're not
gay she was as feminine and you don't
get more hey hey look at me what he gay
so what's the controversy around it is
there any or no people are just oh I
don't why don't you honey gives a
[ __ ] yeah I don't think so or just do
like it Victoria see fans are suffering
bad thing not making money so they did
their toilet your lows are trying to do
some show runways I know the clothes
actually here they're not doing good in
general Victoria's Secret is it yeah
Jared down they have to bet it's true a
lot like most girls that I knew back in
like the thousands that even they always
want to go to Victoria's Secret and now
that's no one look at her face the
pressive hey hey go to the floor left
though that's funny
there's only one where I'm like okay
that's it looks like Bryan on his knees
a little bit
oh they just dropped out the Navy
ceiling maybe see alive that's a girl to
me man really
the body is feet my spidey sense
see I'm not in this one I work with
curves man I'm not about help power
through air and skin is different
sometimes with a man and a woman men
burn hotter so your temperatures little
man could feel that you know so our boy
boy Stevie blue eyes he said come out
and I meet this girl he's with and she's
sexy and she hugs me and she's I was
there bro you were there I was there
whatever and you said something's up and
Stevie was I think something is and he
just wasn't attracted to her and I was
like there's something going on and then
it turned out she was a guy they had a
huge [ __ ] between her like what I saw
I'm like oh that's a dude my spidey
sense is so yeah you got good size
census yeah you said it right away you
said it right away I'm still hot
yeah which it is fun like going around
the hollywood west hollywood area
sometimes because people are so nice to
me maybe it's cuz i gelled my hair and
have a little high cheekbones that like
you did like i got a hotel and had
someone like hey sir just come lion he's
like I'm gonna see if I can get you
checked in early and I was like dude
this dude's [ __ ] night you might try
to [ __ ] me but I'm okay because I want
to forget in my room drinks tonight you
know I don't know they feel like it's
pretty cool right quit complaining I I
don't mind it you know it's like this is
the Victoria's Secret girl yeah I mean
that's a girl man right the face is for
sure but the body my spidey sense goes
but no skinny girl she looks very if
anything I wouldn't care about our
sexual preference reading like that it
would be more let's get you some some
quality food let's make sure you're
happy and I'm being concerning for the
rack a ribs I would also get some roll
eject some fat in the in the ass that's
one same put the fat in the ass ceiling
Butler she's not so bad yeah but ass
she's your ass what's that we have
friends who got presumed but really did
she ain't got enough fat to pull and put
it back in there and we don't want to
promote changing your bodily image you
know that's an ass I know I promote it
or you could take a bunch from you and
fill it out I think three fat jokes on
I'm sorry bro I'm not trying to fat
shame I think your buds bro
but he's pushing me dude he's got it
he's got some dude I'm only do this
because I saw his you know for 15 days
now bro I'm good daddy's down seven what
do you think happen in a month well
you're not gonna have any more serious
unless it's our bet he's gotta get down
there one to 35 by October 5 whoa that's
not gonna happen
are you doing that fitness challenge
thing that Rogen always does though you
started my silver October October the
khalsa October I call it life bro oh you
and Brennan would crush those guys at
that
yeah the beautiful face though I mean I
would kiss her you do more than that
Playboy what else you got debt there we
have it so a 70 year old British man
went in for a bladder operation and came
out with a circumcised penis he ended up
winning 20,000 pounds in a lawsuit
that's it right on the pounds
yeah also I feel like they did him a
favor although snip you got a you know
anteater again I just have makeup on my
penis so I don't know I don't I don't
have an ear I got I got my smile it's
out bro is it I feel you have an auntie
I'm jealous
yeah what are you thinking I was born in
Korea I don't know aegeon countries and
yeah unless you're super religious like
Christian did circumcisions generally
Asians are a well that's something
that's not the worst thing like can you
imagine if they went and gave him a like
gender reassignment surgery and your
dick got lost off then I'm [ __ ] mad
cuz that penis is my life right but also
he's set a little a little bit a little
bit of foreskin you're all right move on
yeah but 20,000 pounds homeboy should at
least got a hundred K out of that at
least right here's my thing with guys
that have anteaters they say it like
because that's how you were born with a
hood for a reason it's more sensitive
loops the thing up it's actually better
but I don't know cuz I was the thing is
more nerves the way that you were doing
this with their hands was denser
hilarious like the wait like wizards but
you can clean it more often I think
that's a lie yeah come on beer no it is
scientifically proven you clean yet the
clean work as you get bacteria oh you
mean pull the hood back like yes dude in
the wish you washing up maybe go don't
have to do that I don't either heads out
pressure washers work great ready to go
let's go let's put our let me see yeah
but see I think anteaters Hollywood aft
does our uncle how are you guys gonna
dock I'm just aunt would you say what
how you gonna dock what do you mean you
know what docking use no bro bro really
wait docking is where one penis yes
those in the other penises for skin and
it docks like a space shuttle
that's not refueling that's like planes
you know but the medical term docking
pissing and then if you get to docks you
can actually go back and forth like a
and you like s you piss into hotdogs in
the corn dogs surely so an anteater gets
with a helmet and they docked up like
they're it's so much for lowering your
legs guys hey welcome to fighters a kid
this is where I do it right I'm loving
this how much more fun is it Bernie's
gonna die any day now yeah
while dockings interesting I also like
here's the thing though you being on
circumcise such an advantage God made
you guys there's some evidence for II
circumcised men are less likely to
attract infections or lower risk for
sexually transmitted
yeah that's White House propaganda but
the thing is is I'm a you know I was a
son is your son circumcised a it's a
tough decision man my kid I didn't want
to do it but my girls super you know
Catholic
Mexican they want to do it I had to
leave the hospital it's such a weird why
in the Bible Moses just a sense bro I
will cut he's that word came from penis
yes to show subservience to God it's
such a weird look at our first it makes
no sense you know but the Old Testament
House is that working
religious needs to be subservient to God
and now we trade on that place it came
from that's the only reason why it's
with the Jewish religious yeah it was
actually a Jewish interesting
then it was adopt in the United States
this could have a health thing and all
that but look at it you're a special
operations and penis expert Brian now he
knows many have been taught that in
Exodus God is seeking to kill Moses than
the response
Zipporah circumcise their son to avert
God's wrath this is supported by the
Midrash midre which is Jewish and
interpreting that passage hold on
but I guess the exit pass also his term
bridegroom of blood in many translations
this passionates provides many students
of the world that's it
he did try to kill Moses I guess hmm
interesting
well it makes sense guess yes we're
doing it
it's so weird though there's no script
or scriptural basis for taking the life
of father does not circumcise a son
punishment for failing to be circumcised
falls upon the child not the father
Genesis 17 for more of the filler to be
circumcised is punishable by exclusion
from the Abrahamic covenant meaning
you're not a Jew anymore not death you
know what dude here's the prom like have
kids have another son coming in November
if it's up to me I'm outnumbered dude I
just my girls all think she's like you
know you're not you're circumcised so
their penis can be different in yours so
didn't be asking on these questions like
you break it down I'm pretty simple kids
are smart as [ __ ] man
you just don't like yeah yeah by the
time you're of that age I don't think
they're gonna be like knowing what your
penis look like it's like that's like
something you learn in sex ed and
probably in like sixth grade or some
[ __ ] I'd imagine you can do it later
hurt more but you can do it later but I
will say this you can do it later stuff
you can do it at 70 or whatever that's
an angel is saying yeah they put him out
but they did my kid might because my dad
was there I had to leave the hospital
somebody and my dad said they gave like
sugar cuz babies that haven't had sugar
they do it early like that when it's two
days old they I'm sure he's like oh [ __ ]
Leo yeah cool right snip my keep even
cry I feel like my dad's lying they
didn't give him by any anesthesia
anesthetic I don't they might but I know
they give they like numb it then they
get a sugar
and he goes oh this is sugar that's like
math for a kid when God imagine you
couldn't put use a lot of like you know
anything that numb the pain on a infant
within reason I use a local local
anesthetic I imagine yeah I'm sure that
hey they had to cut off a lot a lot of
skin we're we're in the trespass telling
truth here man
hey yeah good genes huh yeah cut off the
lottery jeans so the doctors like is
like a sheep what else we got
just watch every second girls handset
said it but it's crazy when you're a
parent you make those decisions yeah so
yesterday Chrissy Teigen came out with
the video saying that equinox and soul
soul should be cancelled because the
investor in both companies is throwing a
big party for Trump over in the Hamptons
it's one of those events where they're
trying to raise money for this campaign
coming up well what's his name that guy
Stephen Ross no the guy the guy [ __ ]
what's his name no the politician who
outed who made public all the Trump
fundraisers and donors you know it's
pretty much all those people are gonna
be kind of right it's it's just kind of
stupid in my opinion because like vote
with your dollar right like if you don't
want to support it don't support it but
like every person can make their
individual judgment whether they they
want to support a company that it's just
like epically when Hollywood comes out
and boycott something I'm probably on
the other side of it annoys me about
celebrities too who are being political
go [ __ ] yourself I just Bob I'm not
saying I did I just have a weird having
a voice a loud voice doesn't make you
political expert that's why I try to
dodge as many the political like I don't
I'm not a political commentator I don't
like research it so like I just [ __ ]
try to stay away from Rosa for a lot of
it so but also like just because your
celebrity have this don't use your
influence to swayed some like let people
decide for themselves also cancel here
panics and cancel SoulCycle a lot of
metaphors and employs a shitload of
people it's a great
Chim like okay and what are you gonna do
about the people who lose their jobs get
the fight you know that's what a lot of
people I understand it's you know what
she's exercising her for like speaking
by the way good person she's exercising
her First Amendment and everything else
I just a lot of times I'm really amazed
when I talk to a lot of celebrities who
have very strong political points of
view and whatever they are at how LLL
inform they are how they really haven't
done their homework a lot of this I'm
not saying about quitting T I don't know
her but I do notice that a lot of
Hollywood tends to be they jump on
bandwagons well they're in a bubble
they're all hot right and they don't do
their homework no when you live in an
echo chamber it's hard to listen to
anybody outside of it and most
importantly we're in a violent culture
where we attack an opposing viewpoint
rather than listen and we watching the
most important thing we can do you're
like I love sitting down with like
someone that's hyper progressive I'm
more you know kind of in the middle and
stuff but it's like fun or either way
it's like let me listen let me shake
some takeaways you might know [ __ ] I
don't probably Bernie Sanders I was all
set to be you know I've always liked
guys social well Bernie Sanders is I
didn't give him a fair shake and I
enjoyed the inner toll Jews
I actually listened I was like I'm not
gonna vote for you but I I think he's
making some good you felt the Bern a
little bit I felt a little bit at least
he's saying look I mean money and these
pharmaceutical companies there there is
there is it a corrupting influence on
our our government that we rob with
money yeah and I mean oh [ __ ] I'm
listening but not so Bernie no sure but
it also Bernie you're gonna die in 20
years bro well let's say 79 so it's very
generous I don't think I'm making it to
79
he's 79 thank you Sarah now you're out
blah blah how old is Bernie
79 I think you're out but I like him but
bernie is very honest I think his ideas
of how to fix things are generally
big government bases every 70 Chasez so
even if you know did you count of the
[ __ ] that big house when 81 what are
we talking about too old yeah what else
we got chin oh yeah but if you're that
late in the game I guess you just gotta
shoot for the moon right you're like
he's pretty dope was present for I died
that's what my thought process
yeah I get it actually that's not true I
probably take all my money and just like
bang hookers and smoke weed Nancy Pelosi
is 79 get the [ __ ] out of here
no Baba why she's giving me I've seen
her in person
yeah she's gonna live longer no she
looks a lot younger look at her fat same
face sound I don't want to
she looks you I'll tell you right now
that Kamla here's an old um the Democrat
from Hawaii yeah you wanna talk see what
else you got oh dude she is straight up
that Trent Aaron have you seen her yeah
no I've seen her she'll shift that dick
to chicken my lord woman she was on she
was on Rogan huh oh no Otis sniffed at
you oh whoa odds dude he is a damn
good-looking woman
Oh with her brain yeah I know what are
we talking about I need a veteran
she's an ex 24 you I'm a little bit more
of a moderate I feel like she's more
moderate I like you I know what's [ __ ]
up I'll vote for ask me one of her I've
no idea where Jen what's her agenda was
her Israeli no okay okay Hawaiian shirts
what's your tonight piece yeah I'll take
her over Connell Harris I don't like
comics at all [ __ ] forward policy you're
hot yeah dude
Rose oh she is a doll Provost Lord it is
painful how hot she is she has to be the
hottest in town the politician mall time
she might be do the bold statement and
very subjective but a new one bro huh
name another one mean she's hooking
woman Brad Pitt okay well okay okay dude
oh when you watched your hottie John I
want you there's an expert on terra's
it's a documentary right on it you gotta
watch that it's so good you're yeah
you'll love it when you watched a hottie
John there's an expert on like Middle
Eastern terrorism and she's this
professor dude yeah I will say does he's
just fact it doesn't happen often but
when I I dated a girl when I contracted
and from where we won't say what what
office if I work Dana oh but what I'm
likin but oh yeah American she [ __ ]
loves Moroccan
smoke show super hot like two master's
degree and then her whole job was to
find really bad people and get them
killed and just like through the bedroom
talk between her and I were stopped
knotch
would never work we're glasses oh [ __ ]
glasses the whole kind of like Plain
Jane but nerdy high five we were like
[ __ ] man I just want to go to like I
don't know and she she was responsible
for what she would like fine her job was
like an analyst yeah she's gonna kick
ask her what a bad yeah she's a kick-ass
girl dude so a white girl hmm
I mean no no wife type of me obviously
but in in that my early 20s a mid twice
no but it is a good but it's not a
goodbye because our USA USA
can you can you imagine that's what I
loved about it where it's like you have
someone that's like planning to kill
these terrible people that just hate
women's rights they don't want women to
vote drive they beat them and she's just
like kill that dude why am rock hard
that's that 12-inch American day rock
hard dude there'd be a me to move it if
I worked in a building you're so
aggressive yeah I want a bang Special
Forces guys and the girls in there no no
not just a girl and then I want to vote
for her what else we got chin came back
collected right there and he's so
superficial they're gonna remake home
alone Disney and its pissed off is it
with blacks racist who are like you're
making oh you're talking about because
like the Alaskan Ariel no that's a drunk
Ariel was green I don't not Aladdin it
was mermaid little mermaid mermaid but
also there's no mermaids don't marry me
why can't you tell people that just go
along be a con suck a home of blacks
trust that is it out on this one you
know was a bunch of Dominicans well not
only just white people upset I never got
that like I I truly believe that I wish
Hollywood would start doing more
original stuff but I get it with the
international market and you don't want
these remakes that are usually trash but
the end
don't [ __ ] buy the movie and don't
watch it because I'm not gonna watch it
I'll go watch the original one yeah I
did watch The Lion King remake and I
thought was pretty dumb I feel I said
I've watered though my son takes all of
them AEI lowborn lanky the thing is with
home alone why [ __ ] why touch it this is
for the streaming service Disney at plus
so it's not like a real huge and I'll
put all the money to it it's gonna be
sort of Macaulay Koken was one of the
burglars I think I said it's been real
[ __ ] up Carly kokkonen have you ever
seen him eat pizza the YouTube video you
gotta watch that one day no after this
yeah he says he responded he said this
is what it would look like with him
forty years later that's dude that keep
that kids living life dude that's
[ __ ] gangster right there what is
that in the play is like eggs or pasta
what does zero [ __ ] he does a podcast
me you see he's still successful he is
yeah doing what yes
from what Jin residuals that you can't
see he still sick and then also his he
has a his own company his podcast
company he it's called like bunny yeah
I'm not joining there's yeah it's called
bunny yeah they're doing well oh he
posted that yes I thought someone
actually look at him cuz it's great I
thought he was gay for the longest no
used to dig Mila Kunis yeah Mila Kunis
yeah never Jamie for a hot me I'm a
fanfic no we're young though yeah no he
was they were in their 20s
Wow Mila she's definitely popping in
Black Snake Moan great flick Natalie
Portman dude he was such a cute kid
you're seeing the kid from Jerry Maguire
used to be so cute now let me see you
now
I guess you can say that you're in a bad
kind of weird for me to like you know
yes cute oh that's no [ __ ] look at that
you're afraid young young and in love in
Hollywood huh uh-huh that's what they do
making movies how she is she married to
Ashton Kutcher yeah she is an FTO oh
yeah they're great together
really yeah I'm sure man you said that
was such resolved great together and he
opened his [ __ ] quarters on the range
isn't he on a show yeah he writes the
range and makes a joke jillion dollars
hmm yeah what else
yeah let's look at my face for some
reason people are upset this has like
been one of the bigger topics I mean
Roby arguing about it maybe a little
yeah me and rip me and Rogan were
arguing about it about Bruce Lee how
they put he was portrayed in Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood hear me I'll be you
chime in on this too I haven't seen the
flick yet so I okay well yeah you
haven't seen either wellness yeah so
here's what I was saying to Rogen I said
I went how about that Bruce Lee scene it
was awesome I'm gonna describe the scene
if you have seen it spoiler alert in
three two one
suck my balls so the thing is is in the
movie Brad Pitt is like a he's a
stuntman but he's a tough stuff man who
can fight and they're on a set of this
Western Bruce Lee's they're like showing
the people how to fight and Bruce Lee
says something like oh I could kill that
guy in one [ __ ] punch and Brad Pitt
starts laughing and then Bruce Lee's
like what the [ __ ] you laughing at he's
like that come on that's not true and as
you want to try it and they get a fight
and Brad Pitt he's like he does his
signature like flying dragon kick and
Brad Pitt's character beats the [ __ ]
like take some beat to that and they
make him seem kind of like stupid like
gimmicky like wow like trying I love it
cuz this because you're like Oh Bruce
oozing about to beat the [ __ ] that's
right Quinn Tarantino went well no
everyone has that manager let's do this
so to me it's a movie it's entertainer
also Bruce Lee has no real record of
being in real character so that's
exactly how dramatic owdown thank you
yes thank that's exact I would probably
go down and probably from wrestling in
Oklahoma or boxing whatever it is I know
some tape Fletcher tyron woodley stunts
they beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] I've yeah but
that like contemporary pro MMA guys with
the progression of the mixed martial
arts but I'm just saying that like Bruce
Lee like what he did for martial arts is
amazing man amazing didn't everything a
life or business plan brought it over
here with it with everything and grew
the sport and mix MMA I don't know if it
even come around for was it for him
that's all fine and dandy when it comes
to real fighting we don't know but we
have heard things on Hollywood sets when
the people are like well no he was an AK
yeah but we do know he was he never had
any fights and we see you watch how he
fights in those movies
he's doing stuff that would not work and
it's not real in real so but that's why
I loved it I I'm telling you I almost
stood on my cheering clap because I went
all Bruce is gonna beat the [ __ ] a
brad Pitt they watch like that's exactly
I would go down right if if what people
are thinking and I loved it yeah Brody
something Logan do you like it
120 just because you want to preserve
the image per se or yeah what he's
saying it's [ __ ] up cuz it makes him
look kind of stupid my arrogant they're
gonna like what he's not supposed to be
I guess and this buyers think we don't
know what yes so there's a guy named
Matthew Pauley who's supposed to be a
biographer of Bruce Lee and says he has
like some knowledge whether it's like
through other people or whatever that he
did get into fights and then beat him up
on set but the challenge refer I know so
there's no real proof if Bruce Lee tried
to fight me said that II would never do
that he would never you always show him
the Muhammad Ali Bruce Lee if I would go
let me know Bruce Lee
every paper Muhammad Li cool no no
they're saying in that movie that Bruce
Lee said that he would beat up Muhammad
Ali when Bruce Lee himself would never
say something like that so they didn't
like them saying that about easily but
here's the other thing Hollywood it's
also fictional Bruce Lee [ __ ]
they love him dude it's a movie that was
crazy
so it's a Quintero's Quentin Tarantino
movie yeah it's not based on everybody
calm down
and yes Morrow Robert didn't speak a lot
everybody calm down it's a [ __ ] great
that's a great movie also the ending the
twist no well that's not it's not good
the Kill Bill thing or whatever
I loved it man but everyone's just
trying to write that the world's full of
hate now so it's like let's complain
about this but this was like the he was
a great he was a great entertainer and
he was a pioneer and he brought martial
arts to the mainstream and he was
incredible
it doesn't mean he was a fighter it
means he was a great powerful
personality one of the great
personalities in the 20th century at
least in American culture there's no
question and impact was incredible
there's also something that I read that
Brad Pitt himself didn't want that
seemed to go that way where that seemed
like he would win shut you like you read
Hawaiian loosely was also a guy who
brought probably gave a lot of respect
to asian-americans where people like you
know especially during that time yeah
like he made it like was cool to be
Asian yeah still is pretty cool he said
I'm getting better being I'm not I'm
more American or Chinese because I feel
human yeah it's like him know again bro
I just quoted Bruce Lee and I don't even
know it well he was a great philosopher
that's the key I did do Bruce Lee drop
loosely drop knowledge man yeah that's
one day you can't take that away from
all I'm saying is in the world I he
lived in Hollywood in a real fight
that's a real guy who knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing that's exactly I
probably would have went Dennis
sorry Bruce Lee nut huggers that's right
Brendan what else oh you what do you
think chin I feel like you want to say
son bro no I don't know Ronnie Lee bro
today bro I'm prickly did you all good
yeah I think Bruce Lee could beat up Jon
Jones
that's fair
what else you got Jim Ruben so here I
only can prove it right this year your
boys the creators of Game of Thrones
they sign a deal with Netflix a
multi-year deal for for doing TV and
film they're you know who did that deal
for a specific show or just ours they're
gonna start crazy on it to get there and
they're do it with the the guy who wrote
Game of Thrones do it's all three of us
two hundred million dollar [ __ ] this
rumor at 200 but people are saying more
no it's more than that because Disney
was going after him hard a lot of people
were going off but they had all everyone
wanted to sign to this deal that made
war bro and here we go they trumped
everything whoa
great dudes be worth a rule shut the
[ __ ] up mark guys man there were people
saying that to you know that when they
sign the deal they're like I'm gonna
stop subscribing to Netflix cuz they're
gonna ruin it or something yeah that's
how crazy okay how do you like something
for eight seasons and then you're mad
about at the end and you just like burn
it all lose their jobs [ __ ] man it's
crazy it's the loud haters on the
internet these days
or that it's fine not to like it but to
like whatever yeah they're not I'm not
gonna make sense of this world anymore
you know this guy Jesus
take the wheel what else uh one last
quick fun one this cute dog on barstool
when I die I want to come back is this
dog I mean look at this dog he's in a
snowy hill and they just like to slide
down it French see this is what we need
the world a little bit of fun and ease
into it you want I'll throw this oh my
god
does he run back up again does a
mountain lion either met then oh hey why
you got a [ __ ] on the plate man trying
to eat some cuteness right now those are
some my favorite videos when they were
released like a little mouse and then
the [ __ ] hawk is of calm and the
families that's cute you when i see
those videos i'm like mother nature yeah
have you haters metal have you seen on
instagram all it every day bro i love
it's like nature show mark oil versus
goat again yes done that yeah we've done
it before
yes well my favorite just picks him up
and drop some yeah them eagle vs. wolf
has create really crazy I was amazed
they killed wolves which one of these
there's more these were super long yeah
but she takes that one for a straight-up
ride you go first is wolf it's crazy
though that first one that's eight
minutes long he takes the goat on a
[ __ ] nine minute it dude sounds
awesome nature is so [ __ ] gangster me
dude breezeless
this like straight come in murder the
whole nest of children let me stop by
and grab this do real quick on the goat
look at this do you think I'll have
those talons in your [ __ ] man on the
go how about the other two just watching
you [ __ ] pricks look at him just
watching no please don't
okay just dragging this thing easy dude
how about the bird just holding those
trying to help them out that is nuts I
want to score this with some epic music
bird is able to just stay on I want to
match in this to Stevie Ray Vaughn wow
wow wow wow that's what that [ __ ]
well Eagle was dominant it says stay in
eyes back
hey kid let's be real I [ __ ] hate
bird that other wanted a weeds legal
you're right let's try another one
no I'd help his friend I say Brian let's
get high and watched planet Earth that'd
be fun
oh look at this nothing like planet
Earth it's here but dude this is crazy
how this ego stand this video sucks he's
just kind of a bat but has it though we
got him off just like watching John fish
fight then she goes off vada I mean he
didn't lift him in the air you go first
this wolf is crazy man
some khabib stuff right there right no I
like it when they get a hold of Huck him
off the rocks
I just wanna shake it gets real well it
got super dark we want to end on the
night he bled sorry guys hey what are
you gonna do Matt birth thank you for my
sir I'll get his book where can they get
it let the people know everywhere books
are sold its song priests are right now
and live everywhere xx is there a thing
more annoying we're gonna get your book
Barnes Noble Amazon will you buy that
anywhere it's bars available Amazon
Walmart I think because I'm a budget
kind of guy how about audible it is I
read my own audiobook no [ __ ] that means
everything dude you got to do your own
[ __ ] steve-o did it too
you got a man like I want the feedback
from the people that support me that
they were like please read and they
wanted to do like the English guys to be
like that's an Army Ranger yeah I just
would have never worked those terrible
pretty sex it's only English law here
yeah that's a ranger I don't even know
but yet the whole time that way
everyone's like okay it was fun dude I
acted all the voices out love it man
like a cool so huh go get his book go
get his goddamn book by black rifle
coffee I think that's it dude it was
nice seeing you guys I missed you guys
yeah man hang out so how long are you
here for just tell him I leave tomorrow
but always a pleasure see you and I'm
not gonna appreciate that for real maybe
tell you know cuz we're trying to close
the show me and the ISIS yeah stay with
me all right man we love you dude this
is the fighter and the kid and the best
we're out